This week would have been the 80th birthday
of iconic martial arts film star, Bruce Lee.
He died unexpectedly at age 32, but his legacy
and his work endure and much in part
to the remarkable efforts
of his daughter Shannon Lee
and in her new book,
Be Water My Friend, The Teachings of Bruce Lee,
is available now.
I've been reading it, it's incredible,
Shannon, thank you so much for joining us.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, thank you.
You know, there was a sentence that really spoke to me.
"How does one honor the plain fact of their DNA,
"while at the same time understanding
"that it doesn't mean anything
"about one's own soul, or does it?
"Throw in my decision to spend a good portion
"of my life protecting and promoting the legacy
"of one of the humans who gifted me with this life
"and who has meant so much to me".
I really appreciated reading that,
as someone who is very loyal,
very inspired by my own family,
and really wanna carry on their legacy
and you've done such an amazing job
carrying the torch for someone who is
so beloved,
idolized.
He is such an important figure, to so many of us.
Well, thank you.
And by the way, thank you for expressing that
and pulling that section out of the book,
so thank you.
So glad.
I just love your dad so much Shannon.
(laughing)
I watched all of his movies, I was obsessed
and when I got to go to make Charlie's Angels,
I showed them a clip reel I made,
like a visual tape of scene-to-scene footage
and one of my big things was Bruce Lee.
And what's it like to have the coolest
most appealing,
capable dad?
(laughing)
I mean, on the one hand, it's amazing, right?
You're like yeah, that's my dad.
You know?
But on the other hand too,
like growing up sometimes
it can feel a little like pressure,
but it's pretty awesome, I mean,
when I was a kid, I used to say to people
when people would say, "Oh, my dad can beat up your dad"
It'd be like, "no but really my dad can,
"my dad could beat up your dad for sure, 100%"
(laughing)
You're like, "my dad can beat up your dad.
"all of his friends in this entire town, in one fell swoop"
Exactly.
Exactly, no but I think what you speak to is really amazing,
his energy,
his dynamism,
his power, his essence,
and how comfortable he was in his skin
and the way he just occupied space fully,
is phenomenal.
It was really interesting to me to understand
when, please tell me if I'm getting this right,
his master was explaining the water metaphor.
I mean, the way he said it is water can flow
or it can crash, right?
Like water is the softest,
most gentle life-giving pliable, beautiful thing,
but it's also can be a tsunami.
And I mean, this is like a lifelong practice, right?
Like how to find balance
and what your particular balance is,
and what's called for in a particular situation.
There's never just one solution,
never just one right answer,
you have to be present to it.
And I think that's a lot like parenting,
I have a toolbox for my kids
and I try to practice a few different things,
so they're familiar and consistent,
but that tool that worked yesterday might not work today,
so I better have a backup plan.
And it's funny too, 'cause my mom
was one of those moms who was like,
I'm just gonna try a bunch of stuff with my kids,
you know, at the tap, jazz, piano, ballet.
And I can't even tell you how like crappy
I felt in a ballet class, I didn't have the body,
I wasn't that type,
and I finally found karate
and all of a sudden I was like,
these are my people.
You want me to punch something?
I have so much anger that I'm supposed to not let out
but I have it in me, but it was the first time in my life,
I remember finding a place,
that I really felt like physically,
emotionally and character wise,
I just felt finally at peace.
Totally.
It gives you this sense of internal strength I think,
which is like the most amazing part of it.
More than the external strength,
it's the internal strength that I love so much.
Before we go, I also found a detail that I really loved,
which is that the San Francisco Giants
hold an annual Bruce Lee night.
Yep.
That is so cool
and as soon as it's safe
I feel like I need to go to this,
because I feel like I will be looking around and going,
I found my people again.
(laughing)
Well, you're definitely invited.
We go every year, except of course for this past year
and you know, especially this year as you said,
it's going to be his 80th birthday.
He was born in San Francisco,
so it's his hometown.
So anytime you wanna come, let's do it.
Well, perhaps next year we can light the torch
for your incredible father,
who made the most important mark
for so many of us, in this world.
I'm so amazed at how beautifully
you're upholding his legacy,
while speaking so many interesting,
internal truths about yourself.
Oh my gosh, everything that you said
like you feel this pull this sort
of like spiritual alliance to your heritage
that is and isn't,
at the same time,
it just resonates so much with me
and so I'm really grateful,
to be able to have a conversation with you
and thank you.
Thank you so much, Shannon Lee.
Season two of Warrior airs Fridays at 10:00 p.m
Eastern and Pacific Standard Time on Cinemax
and seasons one and two are streaming on HBO Max,
so you can check it all out.
Cute boys doing fun stuff.
Thank you Shannon so much.
Thank you.
(gentle upbeat music)